vous faites quoi à partir du 26 juillet
2024 nouvelle étape ce matin dans
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques de
Bordeaux
si on nous fait confiance
c'est tous les jours il faut la
conquérir c'est que McDonald's son
premier marché c'est les États-Unis son
deuxième marché c'est quoi votre avis
c'est la France
dans le pays de la gastronomie on croit
que la France c'est le pays de la
haute-gastronomie c'est le pays des fast
foods
là question complémentaire puisqu'on
parle de spécificité de ce beau pays qui
est la France quel est le monument le
plus visité en France
donc si on se résume la France c'est le
pays
de ce sont les deux Mabel de notre beau
pays c'était la chronique économique
d'Éric Zemmour
les personnalités de l'extrême droite
aucun aucun
de la première présidentielle d'Emmanuel
Macron Marine Le Pen avait été reçue
mais lors de la dernière campagne on a
reçu aucune personnalité démocratique on
n'a pas on n'est pas un service public
vous savez on est sur une chaîne privée
donc on fait un petit peu ce qu'on veut
mais nous aussi on a une chaîne privée
mais on fait pas ce qu'on veut
et alors mais qu'est-ce que ça fait une
info voilà qui a choqué
à la listeria rappeler dans toute la
France cnews est parti en spécial y
a-t-il trop de beurre en France ils vont
inviter Éric Zemmour qui va dire voilà
comme par hasard encore la faute
desmeurs brisurfeu je l'avais dit un
beurre ça va mais deux évidemment on ne
les tient plus le plus réalisme sur
cette chaîne attendez je termine les
règles ça me pose à tout le monde mais
ce que je peux terminer je veux bien que
vous défendiez ça me dérange pas mais je
termine avant le plus je peux terminer
voilà d'ailleurs j'avais pas commencé le
pluralisme le plus réalisme depuis
quelques jours une oeuvre exposée au
Palais de Tokyo suscite une vive
polémique au sein même de l'Assemblée
nationale
Pablo de Myriam Kahn qui présente aux
yeux de tous une scène de pédocrinalité
pointer du doigt par cette membre du RN
est relayée par d'autres députés de
gauche ce tableau où l'on voit une
personne pratiquée de force une
fellation représenterait un enfant mais
la ministre de la Culture interpellée à
ce sujet a tenu à défendre l'artiste et
à livrer une autre version à la lettre N
du dictionnaire on trouve le mot nique
tes mères ou nique tes pair
[Musique]
nique ta mère oui bien sûr ça vient du
grec nuctose nuit et émerage jour il
désigne l'espace de temps comprenant un
jour à une nuit donc 24 heures et donc
ça correspond à un cycle biologique
nique tes mères pour elle c'est une
dénonciation des crimes de guerre voilà
ce qu'elle dit ce ne sont pas des
enfants qui sont représentés
si des panneaux d'avertissement ont bien
été mis en place à l'entrée du bâtiment
pour prévenir les âmes sensibles de
nombreuses personnes souhaitent
aujourd'hui aller encore plus loin je
demande solennellement à la ministre de
la Culture que ce tableau soit décroché
non mais laissez-moi
manger ma banane tomber laissez-moi
tomber laissez-moi
manger ma banane tout nu sur la plage
non je ne veux plus jamais
ma vie est moi je vais résumer pour pour
tout le monde comme je sais bien le
faire celui qui me dit qu'il ne voit pas
un enfant avec les mains attachés dans
le dos en train de sucer un adulte et
celui-là
et puis celui qui m'explique que
derrière tout ça il y a tout un tas de
trucs formidables et ben je l'encule
merci et on est là au taquet retenez
bien son nom père Maurice dossard 25 à
ses côtés père Jean-Yves le dossard 14
qui fait trembler toutes les communautés
on a envie de montrer le meilleur de
soi-même c'est pour ça j'espère bien oui
vous êtes pas là pour rigoler non c'est
aussi
hier on a quand même bu 4 apéro
donc là ça devrait tourner quand on
commence à dire ramenez ça la
pédopornographie et Machin comme tu le
faible comme la barre PMU
que dans les pays où les œuvres ont les
détruit ou on les juge où on les
interdits ce ne sont pas des démocraties
vous êtes des tarenaux
[Applaudissements]
elle reste en travers de la gorge
amertume
tous montagnards
sur les skis
mais revoilà notre père en soutane qui
n'a jamais lâché ses plantes il aurait
pu choisir les chasseurs alpins mais il
est devenu curé de la paroisse d'Arles
même si la raté sa première manche il
n'a pas perdu son sens de l'humour
[Musique]
alors un homme avec une énorme tête
décidé
c'était un télescope bon à 23% de cette
génération enfin en tout cas des 15-24
ans pense que prendre la pilule du
lendemain est efficace pour empêcher la
transmission du VIH encore un peu plus
grave 18% d'entre eux pensent que
prendre un paracétamol peut empêcher la
transmission du VIH donc ça commence à
devenir un petit peu compliqué il va
falloir effectivement faire 99%
et de ma fidélité malgré la solidité du
moment Pascal gitan catalan jusqu'au
bout des doigts ne peut s'empêcher de
faire un clin d'œil à sa communauté
[Musique]